Yep.
-Nope.
-Yep.
You cheater!
Well, that was productive.
Wait! Oh my God,
I just remembered something.
No!
Wait, is that
what I think it is?
Here's our beach
bucket list!
-What?
-Oh my God.
A long time ago,
Lee and I put together a
list of all the crazy things
we wanted to do together
before going to college.
It was all of our childhood
summertime dreams
and fantasies listed out
on one very important
piece of paper.
Damn, we put together
a solid list.
We did.
Good morning!
It is one o'clock
in the afternoon, sunshine.
Sports drink and aspirin
are to your left.
Oh, yes please.
One, two, three!
Go!
We got a winner!
We're making
dreams come true!
Ladies and gentlemen,
we have a winner.
Yeah!
This is amazing.
-You've done this before!
-I swear to you I've not.
We built this city
on rock and roll
We built this city…
We built this city
on rock and roll
You know, we're not going
to be able to do
all of
our bucket list items.
Bucket list item number 22:
"Live together at Berkeley."
This one was going
to be tricky.
Hey! Erm…
I've been thinking
and what if I just went up
with you now?
We go up to Berkeley.
We'll find an apartment,
get set up.
It'll be like
we're moving in together
without the actual,
you know, moving in part.
Hmm…
I accept your offer.
I got off the wait list.
Harvard.
What?
Stop, stop! Put me down.
Shit.
I can't just not be upset
about this, Elle.
You're leaving me.
Lee, I don't know
what's going to happen.
But, what I do know is that,
no matter where we are,
you're always going
to be my best friend.
Are we still good
for the arcade later?
Yeah.
I'm glad you remembered.
Of course.
I wouldn't miss it.
Shit!
Lee?
I'm so sorry.
Somehow
I'll make this up to you.
That is what this
entire summer was about.
Making it up to me.
Well, forget it.
I don't need it.
You seriously cannot be
this upset.
It is just a game, Lee.
Is that really what
you think this is about?
The game?
What, do you think I'm five?
It's not just about
the damn game, Elle.
It's about you fighting
for our friendship.
Lee, I know you're upset,
but…
I don't matter
to you really!
Not compared to him.
I never have!
I…
I heard about you and Noah.
Yeah.
So then come to Berkeley
with me!
It's worth a shot.
This is what
I'm talking about, though.
I chose Boston
to be with Noah
and Berkeley to be with you.
I can't figure out who I am…
on my own.
Come here.
I'm really sorry about
what I said at the arcade.
I didn't mean it.
Yeah, I get that.
That's ok.
A lot of it was true.
And I am sorry
we didn't make this
our most memorable summer
ever.
I don't know.
That may be exactly
what we did.
It feels so weird
to be leaving without you.
I added a new one.
Rule number 35:
"Always call your bestie
every time you miss them."
I love it. Thank you.
Hey, what's up?
-I think I got in!
-Yes!
Ok. You have to tell me more
what happened.
So, Lee and Rachel
did end up
getting back together again.
It turns out that,
sometimes,
people do find their way
back to each other.
Lee and I stayed connected
all through college
and, after graduation,
Lee moved back
to Los Angeles.
And, for us, it was like
no time had passed at all.
We had both changed a lot,
but our friendship hadn't.
And, in the fall
of that year,
we all found our way back
to a very familiar place.
Oh my God!
No way!
And, suddenly, there it was!
-Lee!
-They're still doing this?
They're still doing this!
Oh my God!